welcome
to truth justice and a better dc
universe
a new future for the man of steel here
at comic con at home
i am marie chavins i am the
editor-in-chief of dc comics
um and i'm excited to share with you
some of our plans for superman today
with titles like legion of superheroes
superman
action comics and our dc feature state
event
dc has planted the seeds for what's to
come with the man of steel
and these seeds are not only growing but
they've already
begun to bear fruit this month
here's some of the talented creators
helping to chart the course for the man
of steel
in 2021 and maybe beyond we have with us
today
tom taylor writer of superman son of
kal-el
we've got philip kennedy johnson the
writer of action comics
grant morrison who is writing superman
and the authority
and mikhail hanin the artist on superman
of the authority
welcome guys thank you very much
um okay so let's let's start with philip
can you tell us a little bit about
what's been going on
and um what is going to happen with war
worlds
in the past few years we've seen
superman and his cast
humanized really really effectively i i
love the way
um we've seen superman interact with his
whole cast
how we've seen the importance of
metropolis to him how
um we've seen what superman means to the
world to metropolis
and i wanted to see superman in a bigger
stage
you know so in the events of the war
world rising arc that we're
showing now we're establishing superman
as part of the universe and the
multiverse and we want to see
superman in the most super yeah we're
really trying to put the super in
superman
as this big and epico scale as we can so
we're introducing some aspects of war
world
um that really highlight that i think we
see him in a just a
bigger frame than we've seen in the past
um
there have been some details that we've
seen that we got from the the bendis run
that i thought were really cool
i love the details that he's given us
about mongol about
the way that mongol takes power like the
mongol
is just a title and we see how each
generation of mongol takes power
um we see the relationship between him
and the war zunes
and um it just really kind of cast my
imagination and so now we're going to
see war world in a much
much more threatening light we're going
to see this new mongol that superman has
not met yet
we're going to see um how much more
threatening he is than
than his predecessors and i'm just super
stoked for everyone to see what we have
coming we what we have coming will
blow out war world is uh make it a much
bigger
part of the dcu and um
yeah we're going to make it bigger older
newer
it's just going to be super exciting
but i have one big question right so
i know that we're gonna go on and we're
gonna have
uh superman son of cowell instead of
just
superman and what i'm wondering and i
don't know if you can share this
is why would clark step away
from his family and the justice league
um without spoiling too much i'll say
that clark
doesn't feel like he has much choice in
the decision he's about to make he um
the things he's going to do he's
compelled to do if that makes sense
i mean he um a big part of the war world
rising story is reminding him that he is
he doesn't exclusively belong to earth
that he's a part of the universe and
multiverse
and um he in this world rising arc
he's reminded of that he's he he finds
himself faced with an injustice that's
too great for him to
to ignore um so something he has to deal
with and we're also in the
in the uh the superman monthly issues
i've done leading up to tom's
epic run which i can't wait for it to
start um
part of that has been establishing
superman's relationship with his son
john and um
leaving john behind actually if anything
makes his decision to leave
a little easier if i mean not rather
rather than harder makes it easier not
because he doesn't
not because he's not going to miss his
son obviously because he obviously will
certainly after the time he's lost with
john
but because of the trust that he has in
john as a hero
himself the trusted he has in john is in
his character his judgment his power
his maturity and using it he knows that
earth is going to be safe in his absence
and there's something that he has to do
so as much as he loves his son and as
much as i love writing them together
as a you know a father and son team
he knows that earth is safe with john
and that's that's a big part of what
sets up john
as the superman of earth so
um moving on to ask tom about that
so john kent has he's been through a lot
in a really short time
i mean he's been a kid he's been the
future he's he's been all over the place
um can you tell us where he is when
superman's son of kal-el begins
well yeah he's obviously he's been
through a lot as he said he's been to
the future
he's been in a volcano um he's been a
small
boy and suddenly been taken away from
his family and he's come back
um to where philip has him now and
reestablishing these relationships
with his dad and with lois and now
our story is about who he is today
and it's about him finding who he is how
the some superman
the greatest hero in the world becomes
the next superman for the current world
and for us i mean
that's it's very exciting but it's the
question i'm asking myself as the writer
is exactly the same question that john's
asking himself
it's who am i what is my role in this
world what is the superman of today
and you know that's a tricky question
you go back all the way back
to when superman first came about in
1938
and he was quite a radical character as
a character we needed at the time his
first story was about domestic violence
it wasn't he wasn't punching space
robots and
today it's about the same question so
for this superman for john kent to say
you know it's easy enough to punch a
space robot
but it's harder to punch social inequity
in the climate crisis for instance
that just i've tried it just it doesn't
work
um so it's gonna be questions that he's
gonna be asking
and we're gonna fill a cast of
characters around him to help him
answer that damian isn't going anywhere
anywhere for
people who fear that the super sons are
still going to be that his best friend
is still going to be there
they're still actually the same age gap
i want to tell all the fans out there
it's just that it's reversed so damien
is now 14
john is 17. um but there's still the
same age gap between the two
so there'll still be friends there'll be
a lot more to it so some
revenge coming up there i think totally
no i think i'm hoping super sons fans as
one myself and my son is one
will be very happy with what we do in
this uh what separates
the john superman from his father the
clark superman
look he's a he's a different person he
hasn't just been raised
by the kent he's the son of superman and
everything that means
you're talking the power the ethics the
the compassion of superman but he's also
the son and this is really important
he's the son of lois lane it doesn't say
it in the title but
lois lane is one of the greatest
champions of truth
and the champions against corruption in
the entire world
and so yes he has everything that his
father has but he also has that fire
of lois and that and that desire to do
good
and to also you know make sure that
everybody is safe and that
corruption doesn't run rampant um he's
the son of
one of the greatest journalists on earth
and we
hopefully that informs a lot of who he
is as a character too
so the the premise of superman's son of
calal is
is truth justice and a better world like
what does that mean does that
feed into what you're saying it kind of
does it's it's that
instance of there's this moment i don't
really want to spoil it but
there's a moment where he realizes he
doesn't just want to fight the symptoms
so it's it's about having that much
power and
trying to work out what you do with it
you know this he can be
a person for change or he can be a
person that just
props up the status quo and a lot of our
story
comes from that it comes it comes from
him
possibly overstepping a little bit and
the powers that then come in to
stomp him back down
so uh okay so going back to um
action so
the um the authority somehow
is is coming into the story is that
right phillip
yes i'm not sure how much i can say
without spoiling
everything yeah yeah i can't take credit
for the authority idea at all although i
would love to i
am uh let's see
i can say that for the next few months
the events of war world rising
will be quickly building to a head a lot
of different threads are coming together
there's going to come a point of
critical mass when the status quo on
earth
will be irrevocably changed and
things will not be able to continue the
way that they are um
they'll have to be changed after what is
about to happen happens
and those will be the months in which
the john kent superman story by tom
taylor
uh begins and john tim uh superman of
the authority come together
in the pages of grant and mikhail's run
uh clark's situation where the justice
league drastically changes his attention
starts to his focus starts to
turn to war world all those things kind
of happen around the same time
and the yes the authority plays a huge
role in that
and the events of superman and the
authority
lead directly into the next arc of
action comics
okay well that seems like a good time to
go over to grant and miguel
i've read the first couple of scripts
and seen the work that mikell's been
doing on them and it is
astonishingly cool and i can't wait for
everyone to see it's it's p grant
morrison pete mckell it's incredible
cool um grant want to tell us a little
bit about
how superman and the authority embraces
superman's history because like my first
reaction was what do those two things
have to do with each other
yeah exactly but it kind of embraces the
history of superman in the sense about
all the different things he's
represented
so very much takes him back to the kind
of radical character that he was
you know when i did him in action comics
we went back to that well of of as tom
said in 1938
was radical and over the years
he's changed quite a bit so we we have
scenes where we see him with president
kennedy in 1963 and
that's explained via time travel or
whatever but there are certain versions
of superman the patrician the dad you
know the kind of
the boy scout and it's kind of where he
is now in his life he now has a son who
can take over for him he can't
trust the boy so it's kind of
if you could imagine almost a midlife
superman you know but what's his mid
life like it's
suddenly wait i mean i no longer have
the chains of this role and this
responsibility on me for all the various
reasons that lead up and
and phillips stuff he doesn't have to be
that superman anymore
and it's because of events of the story
is in a particular position where he has
to bolster
his powers as well so he's kind of
looking for a team of people
who can almost who can stand in for all
of his powers
and at the same time you know he's still
a magnificent superman he's
maybe you know he still has power he's
looking for people who can almost
represent them
so it's kind of about a superman who
doesn't have to be
what the world that wants him to be
anymore and
suddenly he's looking at himself and
thinking have yeah
it's not so much have i not achieved
i've achieved all this but
was this what i wanted when i was 20.
you know now that i stand here and look
at my own son was this what i wanted
so it was again i think all of the
events of everyone's stories has been
put in superman in that position but he
suddenly
the cape is off and he can really think
about how to do how he might create
change and
embrace his kryptonian side a lot more
embrace his intellect
embrace his compassion and all those
kind of different things and to see
if he can actually make changes in a way
that he hasn't done it before
cool so um why does he need to form a
new team or can we talk about that i
don't know if we don't want to give
anything
i don't know i mean the reason he's
forming a new team is because he powers
a diminishing like i say he's kind of
he's trying to put people in place but
there are three levels of wise forming a
new team as well
and each one and it kind of peels back
as as we go through the story we start
to understand all we thought it was for
this reason
but it's actually for the rest reason no
it's actually for this third reason
which is even bigger and more important
but yeah there's a lot in play and he's
chosen these particular characters as
well
and he's working with manchester black
who's a character who hates superman
who spent his entire fictional career
trying to humiliate and destroy superman
and suddenly
this guy is asking him to be is the the
leader of his team what is going on here
why is
how did you choose the um other
characters on the team was did you
sort of say hey michael who do you want
to draw or or what
you know i mean not so much that the
characters came about because
i was looking at the original authority
team and i thought well are there other
characters in dc
i used uh midnighter and apollo from the
original team
but i thought were there other
characters in dc who could speak
stand-ins for
the types of characters who appeared in
the original authority series
so in place of the engineer you know
it's a nano
machine controlling uh like you know
half half women half machine
we've got steel or you know natasha
natasha ions who steals the water
in place of the the doctor we have the
enchantress
in place of you know in place of
swift we have light ray and so on so the
idea was kind of
put analogues over the analogs in from
the dc universe and see if we could make
a team
that felt similar but wasn't the same
and looked different and there's a bunch
of characters there that
we haven't seen for a while or we've
never really seen before in this way
so it's an interesting mix of
personalities and characters as well as
duplicating the powers of the original
authority
mikel so let's talk about designing
the new characters um and maybe maybe
your take on the old ones what's it been
like
uh collaborating with grant on these
characters and on the whole
series and how did you approach
characters like light ray and the new
omac
well first off working with brand
is a dream made true and
just seeing subscribers i think
fantastic i love your stuff
thanks so much so it has been so
inspiring
since the moment i started to read
the the pitch and the script and how
every character is described there and
the ideas start coming and well
i've been working now for dc like
10 years i think this year i made 10
years
and the the first team i designed was
the justice league dark
when a new 52 came out
and i was very naive at that moment and
i didn't really knew what i was doing
and now i think i for better or good
i i do know what i'm doing so i wanted
to
to make those characters uh have
a bit of their previous story especially
with
clark or apollo or midnight or
midnighter
that are very well known for for the
readers
and having fun with the new characters
like
omac or or light ray and
what i tried is that everyone works
by themselves as a design
and together the balance of colors the
balance of
sizes and shapes everything uh
works together like like a strong image
have you given superman a new look yeah
yeah that was part of the deal and
yeah uh it was pretty easy because
we had the depiction of grant in the
street
with a kind of sporty look
like something very modern and
also i took a bit the image of the new
52
from grant and rex morales design of
that young clark and a bit of the
classic kingdom come from
alex ross the shield and all that
and merging all together i think we have
a
new design for superman and i think it's
cool it works for me
um going back to tom you do you have
also
a new look for your superman or john
kent
i'm not sure if we're allowed to admit
to that yet but
sure yes yes we do um what you've seen
on the cover two issue one uh will
change
so yes superman our superman john kent
will be getting a new book
and what did you have to do with uh john
timm's for that
uh not much honestly john's just really
really really good
so it was one of those instances where
he actually
he kind of had it before i came on board
i mean we've been talking for a long
time about doing this book but
he had this look and it was instantly
just yes that's it normally i'm
really really really fussy and i get you
know
annoyingly so uh but for this it was
just like that's looks
wonderful go um that's what we want to
see
did lois get a new look too though god
loves doesn't have a new look yet but
it's something we'll talk about
yeah yeah would you like her would you
like to design the hacker
no i don't think you should leave that
to me that's that's not going to work
so i'm not the haircut phillip going
back to you for a second where is lois
in in your title
uh throughout the world rising arc she's
i mean we're seeing a lot of lois in
this in this arc that's happening now
with the super family as they learn more
about who the war world refugees are
um what the fragment is uh who this new
mongol is what he's trying to do
she's very present in all that we see uh
clark and john lois and supergirl and
crypto they're all
all part of the scene um
it is probably not much of a spoiler to
reveal that clark's going to war world
soon
and as as such um
with the story we have coming up in war
world it didn't feel like lois had a
as solid a place in that story as she
would as a as a part of john's story on
earth as he's getting as as he's
you know getting his footing as the
superman of earth so for
for a while she's not going to be
present once
the war world rising arc is over and we
get to war world
proper um she's not going to be
with clark um in person for a bit but
she does have a pretty huge role coming
up there as well
down the line that we can't get into yet
that would be a massive spoiler but
she's going to be very important in
action as well um
a little bit further down the line okay
um how so let's talk about
these war will so superman has plans
right so
how are you weaving in his plans for a
better war world
into your title philip and then how does
it
work in grant's title and then we'll
switch to grant for that
i don't know well shoot i'm sorry i
don't think we can really talk about
what the plans are for warwill just yet
because it's that's still so far
like the world rising arc is happening
for
for a bit yet um
his plan for war world is it hinges on
where things go in the next few months
yeah i'm sorry i can't really get into
it without completely
well in the book sadly uh
but uh and i don't want to give up the
the role that the authority plays grant
what do you have anything to add
no i mean i we don't really want to see
i mean the thing with the authority book
particularly is that it's putting the
team together
so it's doing like the very end where
you see that kind of connective tissue
so no i don't want to spell any of the
secrets or
or how it ties in but yeah i mean once i
found out what philip was doing i was
able to jigsaw the whole thing in but
really the authority book is about
watching how he puts the team together
with manchester black
and then we kind of build bridges from
the last issue
how did the two of you collaborate on
that did you just sort of keep each
other in the loop or was it
did the story evolve as you each gave
each other uh
input again again for me it was uh i
mean i had a couple of
zoom calls with philip and he told me
what he was doing so this this kind of
came before
i knew it was what he was doing so like
i say the the four issues of the
authority are very much their own thing
and then we were able to take threads
from it or pull little pieces out of it
and make uh
really interesting connective bridges
which again no one can talk about it
right now but there's some really cool
little
twists that i wouldn't have had in the
story if i hadn't been able to
enter philip yeah i
am i my introduction happened with the
the super team in editorial after
we did the last god at dc black label
and
i got the impression that the reason i
was approached was because i
established a rep as the guy who's
willing to sink 10 times too much
time into world building like developing
like languages and songs and religions
and
you know ancient texts that don't even
appear on the page and
like just tons and tons of stuff and so
i i really
leaned into that hard and did a ton of
world building to make
war world a real place um
because we want to uh
yeah we're trying to just tell as epic
a superman story as we possibly can i'm
really i'm looking back to
um you know superman 400 from
the old days where the the uh the big
anthology of the uh
the future story anthology that uh so
impactful back in the day
and um that that cover um
was that annual number 10 i think with
the the sword in the front and all that
i think these
iconic moments from my memories of
superman comics as a kid and trying to
make the most
just blow off the page epic superman
stories as we can and so i just leaned
into all that and made this huge
sprawling frankfurzeta superman space
epic
you know and um i i have this
gigantic doc about what what's coming
and
that all got sent to to grant and then i
got to see what grant had planned for
his story with the authority which
like everything grant writes just
completely blew me away i mean
just to get to work with grant and tom
is such an honor
i mean i mean tom just walks into every
book he's writing like
hey look at me i can make any comic 10
times cooler than it should be
and grant is like hey i'm the most
creative writer who's ever lived and i
can just
write the most creative thing you've
ever seen and just make me feel like a
child
every time i read a comic he's written
and it was just such
yeah it's just so inspiring to see
everything that they do so yeah i
the the doc that uh my world building
doc went to grant
and grant's um plans for the authority
came back to me and i got to read his
early scripts and
um i just really tried to capture some
of that magic and
and the magic he created that they
created on all-star as well
um and try to capture just a
just a kernel of that creativity for
what we have coming in war world
well of course we also have our art end
of things um mccall
i have a question for you so
you have done so much work on that other
guy
batman um over the years many
many issues and iterations of batman
so a question for you is how is drawing
the caped crusader and the man of steel
different how do you
approach it differently well they
they are really very very different and
not only in their personality but in
their
physically so i think the
shorter answer is that when you draw
batman
no matter what you do it's always going
to
look cool so you just focus
in the the cape and the dark shadows and
all that
but when you're working on superman
superman is very
much more difficult than batman
and you focus more on the
face and the body language so
you try to to keep the spirit in every
panel
so every time you draw him saying
something
maybe simple maybe just talking
but he he must appear like superman
so you you have to capture this
personality in
every in the mouth in the eyes and
as grant said in the script it's like
there's never
on his eyes okay so that's that's the
and you have to capture this in every
time
so it's more difficult to draw superman
but it's very satisfying
is it more difficult to write superman
for the rest of you
no for me i mean i love to write
superman he's just
and what i love about is is the
humanity of superman but also the fact
that he's an aspiration figures
is he asks us to think of the best
version of a human being and sometimes
that's a lot harder than thinking of the
worst guy which is much more fun you
know how to be evil and bad
but to put yourself in the position of
someone like superman just found as a
writer is really
inspirational it makes you think of
utopian ideas that otherwise you
wouldn't be able to do
and it kind of pushes your imagination
into places that people
don't find it easy to go you know to
think what what does a really good
person think like that's that's hard for
us to think but superman forcibly into
that and that's kind of what i love
about them so
i don't find it difficult it's uh it
elevates me to think like superman
yeah i would totally agree that's
um what they said about elevating like
feeling elevated as they write superman
that's exactly right
i mean i i just i love having superman
in my in my head
um i don't want a superman i can relate
to that does the same
dumb selfish things that i'm tempted to
do i want somebody that i
aspire to be like always and that's
that's what he should always be in my
opinion
someone who wields absolute power
often um but wields it with absolute
compassion and humility
yeah and also able it will go it will go
10 rounds
for people you know and that's the other
thing superman isn't just
a passive character he takes it he takes
it to the floor i mean the guy
will punch out evil and again that's
what i love i love the brawler aspect of
superman the champion
aspect and i think it's it's but it's
always done in the service of someone
who knows that what he's doing is right
most of the time in fact pretty much all
of the time
yeah look for me i mean superman has
always been my hero
from as young as i can remember i mean
that's that's there for a reason
um i did put this t-shirt on for you but
but he has he's been my hero for as long
as i can remember i was raised by a
single mother
um and i had superman to look to
and as a writer it's all i've ever
wanted to write because
for me i mean it's what grant was saying
angst is easy earnest is harder but
inspiration is so worth it like being
able to write a character
that you look to and love who and who's
there for you and who's
fighting for you and believes in you
that's you know that's absolutely worth
it and that's superman
well that's it then um thank you to
everyone for for stopping by to watch
our discussion and for tuning in
and thank you to all of our panelists
tom taylor philip kennedy johnson grant
morrison and mikhail
hanin superman son of cal number one
superman the authority number one and
action comics number 1033
are all available now at your local
comic book store and participating
digital platforms such as comixology
amazon
and apple for the latest on superman and
all our dc characters
visit the website at dccomics.com
and follow on at dc comics at dc
superman and at the dc nation
on social media thanks so much for
stopping by